is it important for you to know the
ending before you start writing your
screenplays
i mean i would love to i would love to
know the inning all the time it'll
be awesome sometimes i have it and
sometimes it changes
um i would love to know as many parts of
the
puzzle as i can
sometimes you discover it and it goes
another way
and i think that's the beauty of
of sitting down and chipping things away
because it might make more sense
uh a lot of times it anchors things and
having an ending
where you're concrete about it um
helps you know and so
but then you might fall in love with the
characters and you don't want you don't
want it
to end that way so um you know again
trying to be
flexible with that is good in in my
opinion but
having it knowing the ending would be
awesome and sometimes i i have that
in my head um and then
and then you you play around with the
themes and then you follow the themes
and hopefully
you could direct direct everything
towards the end you know
so that would be my process i don't know
what works all the time
but as a rule that sounds like you don't
always have to to know the ending before
you begin something
yeah i think so i think so um
it would be very helpful and it will
just guide and help
guide but um
i think you have a gist of your story
and then if you have that just then you
probably could get to the ending
you know quicker than you if you don't
have that
with all roads to perla did you know the
ending
as you begin i had an idea of an ending
now knowing how to tie it all up
it took me a while um
i remember i did have like i know how i
wanted to end
but how it what but how how it ended
um was still up in the air because there
were so many loose parts
um i think one of the things that i've
found
even with the script in the early stages
is i don't know if anyone out there has
a similar problem
your lines sometimes it has to
you gotta wrangle them back and and have
that fit
on it and that that was the trick tricky
part you know
and not make it seem so forced in things
and massage it correctly
and um and get still get your message
across
or you know what the story's about so
yeah
when i started i had an idea what's
going to happen
um but uh you know without giving
anything away
it it it was it guided
but the little details was harder you
know
maybe help me understand that so is it
almost like if you're gonna search for
halloween decorations but then you go
down this rabbit hole and now you're
searching
fall you know you're you're going and
then you're like you know what wait my
original plan
was to look for halloween decorations is
that so we're talking about where you go
you have to wrangle it back in yeah like
like
let's say for instance i had um
we had skeletons we had zombies and we
had
you know we have ghosts uh
but only the ghost is at the end
you know what happened to the skeleton
and the zombies without it
becoming did we forget him at the aisle
14 or you know like
or did it or did they disappear or did
the ghost take it you know so
if you knew that the ghost is the one
that's there
at the end because you just you don't
you
you know in the front yard then maybe
you want the zombies in the back
later you know you know you know you
have the elements but you know you
thought like
you wanted the ghost to be the one that
is the main highlight
um i think that's what i'm kind of
talking about more
like i have an idea i want the ghost to
be my the guy out there but
how do i what i do with the rest of the
crew i mean that
interesting okay and and do do we really
need to know
how much and why you've left the
skeleton in the aisle 4 or 14 whatever
that goes back to our discussion of do
you want to hand hold
more or do you want to leave it
leave it um leave it
leave it a little bit more obscure
you know so do we leave a foot out
then you see the skeleton foot in aisle
or do you want the entire leg out or do
you want the entire body out so you
could see
that he that skeleton got killed at
aisle 14
you know that kind of stuff so that's
the that's what's
i think what i'm talking about in terms
of like i have an ending
i have a feeling ending how do i get
there
with all these other other things that
are happening but then sometimes you go
you know what
actually the skeleton should be the one
that's at the end
you know that so that could happen you
know but with all rows of perrla
i had it i had a feeling what i wanted
my challenge was like
i know i knew the last page
my challenge was the five pages prior to
that last page
you know that kind of thing of you know
tying things up
and getting it right and who's and how
do we get there
to make it kind of you know dramatic and
um suspenseful things like that
you